de los siete aspirantes al sillón
presidencial en chile 2 se perfilan para
la segunda vuelta según los sondeos
aunque no aciertan desde 2019 el
izquierdista gabriel boric del frente
amplio y el ultraderechista josé antonio
kast del partido republicano por primera
vez en la historia de la democracia
chilena ninguno de los dos favoritos
forma parte de las dos coaliciones
tradicionales de centroizquierda y
centroderecha que durante más de tres
décadas se repartieron el poder hay una
posición entre una cierta creo yo en
libertad de los votantes
para elegir opciones que están fuera
quizás de lo comúnmente tomarían por
razones más más identitaria y también
creo yo que hay una especie de
muchos votantes que se sienten huérfanos
en el sentido que la que no hay que las
alternativas por la que tradicionalmente
votaban ya no son alternativas viables
el estadio social de 2019 que dio inicio
a las peores protestas desde la
dictadura marcó un momento clave en el
país sudamericano también la presunta
implicación del actual presidente de
chile sebastián piñera en los papeles de
pandora ha generado aún más desconfianza
hacia los típicos partidos aunque piñera
asegura que las acusaciones son falsas
ayer el senado rechazó una acusación
constitucional
basada en hechos falsos
suposiciones o meras conjeturas y sin
ningún fundamento
quiero reconocer la actitud de los
diputados y senadores que actuaron con
seriedad y responsabilidad
es la primera vez en 16 años que ni
piñera ni michelle bachelet gobernará en
el país el 21 de noviembre casi 15
millones de chilenos votarán en la
primera vuelta por su candidato de
preferencia la segunda vuelta se
llevaría a cabo el 19 de diciembre